this is awful
I have a very close friend that didn't
make it today
and I have another close friend who
didn't either and one who's at the
hospital
that I hope is is going to make it
through
so when we talk about praying I hope
people will
for those that we
are hoping can make it through the
surgeries that they're going through
and then we've got to do what we have
done these last three years after
everything we've got to wrap our arms
around these families
and everybody who needs it don't be
afraid to get some help
our bodies and our minds are not meant
to go through these types of tragedies
and so I hope that all the brave
officers have stepped into the line of
fire that are worried about one of their
fellow officers
will reach out for help when they need
it I hope every one of those Bank
employees and folks in that building one
that I know well
and My AG campaign was out of that
building
I know virtually everyone in it that's
my bank
I hope that they will all reach out and
get the help that they need there are a
lot of people that are hurting today
and if we have a place to focus our
energy I hope it is to surround them
with the love
and the compassion that we have been so
good at showing one another
I want people to know that while today
is a horrific act I do believe that this
is a safe Community with officers doing
their very best each and every day and
that's what we saw here